Kellie's with us in Billings Montana hi
Kelly welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave
thank you for taking my call I am just
at a point where life didn't just smack
me in the face it straight-up came up
and cold-cocked me Oh hurts I'm sorry oh
but you know it was the wake-up call my
husband and I needed and you know I just
ordered the home-study SPU and finally
got my husband on board with budgeting
and everything it's kind of a good thing
however we're in a situation where I'm a
medical courier and we bought my car so
I could continue doing my job but the
payments are 450 a month so I just don't
know if I should try and throw any extra
money at this car get it paid off ASAP
should I try and sell it and try and get
something a little older that's owned
Padgett don't know so how much do in the
car about nineteen five okay and what's
your household income together net we're
bringing home about six thousand a month
between the two of us because I've been
working 80-hour workweeks picking up
extra hours where I can net so you
making like 80 grand a year total
roughly yes okay all right and how what
is the other car worth the other car may
be worth six grand but we owe 17 on it
hey it was a bad deal bad bad deal so
you are 16 and 17 on cars what other
debt do you have various little medical
bills and about 2,500 to the IRS total
how much not counting the cars I'd say
about 40 to 45 more altogether Oh
including the cars Oh including the cars
yes okay so so and you make 80 all right
so here there's a couple of rules of
thumb I use on a car okay I like my car
I'd like to keep it
am i smart to do so if that's the
question I measure that two ways one is
you should never own vehicles that's the
total of everything you have with an
engine in it even if it's all paid for
more than half about half your annual
income because everything with an engine
in it goes down in value and if you've
got more than half your annual income
tied up in that something that's going
the wrong way then you've got a lot tied
up in stuff going wrong way that's so
that's a rule of thumb you're not there
you're below that the second the rule of
thumb I use is can you be debt-free but
your house if everybody is on board and
you're focused and you're going to go
crazy and you're going to do this and
you're going to do scorched earth on
your lifestyle and so forth can you be
debt-free cars and everything but the
house in two years and the answer is yes
okay can you pay off can you pay off
twenty thousand dollars a year making 80
grand the answer is yes okay and so you
could keep the car if that's the thing
the thing that bothers me though that's
a third part that's not normally a third
part when you drive your vehicle for a
living you are putting an adorning
amount of miles on it and so when you
drive your vehicle for a living whatever
you're driving you are destroying its
value how many miles a year you're
putting on a car just the last three
months alone about 25,000 miles okay and
so that translates to a hundred thousand
miles a year and yeah it hurt yeah so
you know what a hundred thousand miles
does to the value of a car it destroys
it you see what I'm saying say so regard
let's pretend you were rich and had five
hundred thousand dollars in the bank and
no debt all right well you still
wouldn't drive any more car than is
necessary to do this job because this
job destroys cars right and so you want
to drive the minimum vehicle that will
get the job done because you're
destroying it now let's get the job done
get the job done is two things one is
you spend all day in a stinking car and
so it has to have a reasonable comfort
level to is it has to be reliable right
and that's the two things it has to be
in order for you to be able to put 100
some miles on it in a year and you're
probably going to buy a car every year
if you keep that up yeah because you're
destroying it I have been looking for
other jobs and I have a prospect but
it's not guaranteed no but I mean if
that changes the equation if the job
changes but you see my point if this is
something you're going to project and do
for many years you've got to say all
right part of the overhead is of this
job is I'm destroying whatever I'm
driving and I want to destroy a ten
thousand dollar car not a thirty
thousand dollar car and so because of
that if you're going to stay in this job
I would sell this car and move down to
about a ten thousand dollar car okay but
not because of the debt just because I'd
rather destroy a ten thousand dollar car
than I would a twenty thousand dollar
car right that I should have never
gotten into this car in the first place
I was uneasy going into it and I'm still
uneasy yeah well that doesn't tell that
that uneasy is God talking to you yeah
and I should have listened yeah yeah
yeah my dad used to say when the bell
rings you need to answer the bell when
that little bell down inside of you is
ringing yeah you answer the bell and it
means don't it when in doubt don't is
what it means
so yeah you you know this probably for
all of those reasons is a sale of this
car even though it does meet the
guidelines of keeping a car that I
usually use okay but for the other
reasons I would probably if I were in
your shoes I would sell it and move down
because the last thing you need is an
extra $10,000 just going out the window
cuz whatever you drive you're destroying
its value if you keep doing this job
you